[Music]  i have like you  heard the tall tales told about the  marsh girl  an abandoned child  i had a family once they called me kyle  [Music]  a little girl surviving in the marsh on  her own  reviled  and shunned  hello miss kyle i hear y'all by muscles  [Music]  sometimes i feel so invisible  [Music]  i wonder if i'm here at all  you are  i think you're gorgeous i want to get to  know you better  [Music]  there's no fingerprints on the railing  great snot  no fingerprints  being isolated was one thing  being hunted  quite another  [Music]  she killed him i know you have a world  of reasons to hate these people i never  hated them they hated me they harassed  me  you want me to pick from my life  i won't they're not deciding anything  about me  [Music]  in spite of everything trying to stomp  it out  the marsh knows one thing above all else  [Music]  every creature does what it must to  survive  [Music]  so  [Music]  you